[Music]
being a hulk asks for balance
[Music]
it's easy
little punk
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things when am i ever going to use this
as a lawyer jen when you have powers
like this it's like putting a target on
your back in the backs of all the people
you care about oh cool yet another way
my life is run thanks bruce all right
all i've been doing is showing you the
downsides of being a hulk but there are
a few upsides
our bodies metabolize alcohol at an
incredibly fast rate
which means
that we can drink so much and not get
drunk
all buzz number
this is good
[Music]
wow jesus what the hell man killing
control no overwhelming feelings of rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely this is a multi-year journey
you're about to embark on
yeah who's your best friend nikki
spandex spandex is your best friend
being a hulk asks for balance
you have so much more to learn
yes
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer i i respect that
he doesn't mean that
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and i want the she-hulk to be the
face of
jennifer wolves
namaste
i have a serious conflict of interest
this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh
people only care because i'm
representing emil bonski i think they
care cause they're like hey that girl's
green
do your thing god i really like this
outfit
i'm not proud of this
miss walters we answer to a higher power
our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
i am a lawyer
we do things by the book
the book of the shanty no the book of
american uh loss
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero let's do this
you know that friend you had in high
school who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
hello
i think i'm jealous is that what i'm
feeling
[Music]
[Music]
you